- [Narrator] If you were alone in a room
with a son of a billionaire,
what would you ask?
(upbeat music)
- Hi, nice to meet you.
- Hey, how are you?
- I'm good.
- Do I like
- Shake hands?
- What's up brother?
- What's your name?
- I'm Bobby.
- Can I give you a gift?
- Yeah.
Wow, thank you.
Amazing.
(Bobby laughs)
- Yeah, I got them at
the dollar store for you,
so I hope you like
- Ooh wow! Cool.
I appreciate it. I'll
keep on. Hold on to them.
- What does your dad do?
- He, he started off
in the music industry.
He started basically the, the biggest
like creative media college,
teaching like music,
production, sound engineering.
And now he has like a
flight at school as well.
And like recording studios
and real estate obviously.
- What industry are you in?
- I'm a, a film director and a YouTuber..
on YouTube I make like,
sort of like short films about my life.
- What would you say
so far your craziest
moment has been in life?
- Craziest moment in my life is definitely
When I was on tour with designer
and we flew into Japan
and I take Adderall.
So I was just prescribed
that by the doctor.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm on tour.
Like I'm trying to be
a productive citizen.
I'm trying to work hard.
And I came in there with that
and I didn't check before
there its like classy, a substance there,
like super illegal.
I went to jail for two months
basically when we landed.
I was sleeping on the floor.
- Oh my! You got like a prison cell?
- Yes, it's like with like a
couple other Japanese dudes.
- Are you single?
- Yes.
(laughs)
- oh okay.
- No, I'm not actually.
I was saying yes 'cause you
gave me the flowers, but no
- That's okay. I barely like guys anyway.
(both laugh)
- How does the amount
of money you have affect
how you interact with women?
- I guess it's given me the
ability to abuse my position
especially like, you
know, with like going out
and partying and the,
and the nightclub scene
and stuff where it's like, I
could hook up with like models.
And obviously that was
like super cool at when I
when I was like 18 to like 21
and I was like, thinking
like, wow, this is everything.
Like, I didn't need a girl to like,
like me and to like, to, to
be in a relationship with like
I just need like a girl who who's gonna be
like super hot and, and act as
like, you know, an accessory.
But as obviously I went
through things in life.
I started to realize
that it's really nice to
have a healthy relationship
with someone that you
actually, you know, love.
- Who's the most famous person
that you've ever got with
- Lindsay Lohan.
I was like, I met, I met her
at the canned film festival
and I ended up, you know
I passed out on her
couch and she woke me up
- On Lindsay Lohan's couch?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oh my!
- So I also wanted to ask what
your relationship was like
with your parents growing up?
- My dad was like, not around really.
He was just building like this empire.
So he was traveling around the world.
Like I never just would
see him like once a year.
That kind of made him like this mysterious
like icon in my life.
Like this guy was like
traveling around the world
and like just making it happen,
you know what I'm saying?
But then my mom was like,
really like the one that
you know, raised me,
taught me everything I know about
compassion and love and
being kind and fair.
- Do you think that people
discredit your talent
and hard work because of
you and your family's money?
- Every single day of my
career as a filmmaker,
I think the way I make my
success, my own is like
with my creativity and, and my talent,
rather than focusing on
you know, trying to make a bunch
of money because I feel like
my dad already did that.
- What is your daily routine?
- You know, it's very varied for me,
sometimes like, I'll, I'll have something
that I'm working towards like one project
Then it would be like a full
day of like working really hard
and like doing a whole bunch of stuff.
Other than that, I'm just editing.
- What's your daily routine like?
- I'm homeschooled.
I go to soccer practice,
but for me, like I'm
kind of like low income.
So, I usually take the bus,
takes me like two hours
- Two hours?
- Yeah.
- How do you feel when you see
like a poor person on the street?
- I've experienced that I did a
I did a show where I was
homeless for three nights.
The people that I, that I
knew that I met on the show
they kind of wanted to stay there
'cause they could make 60 pounds in a day.
So for them, they were
like, why would I go
and work when I could
just sit here and put a
my head down across my
legs and get 60 pounds
they're gonna go buy weed, alcohol.
And they were like, they had
more food than they needed.
- Don't you feel like you
could do like a little bit more
'cause you have that money.
- When I see poor people, like sure.
Like maybe I, I want to help them
but like how?
The world is, isn't a fair place.
Like I don't have time
to spend my entire day
going around, like looking
after homeless people.
That's not who I am.
I'm focused on like building stuff
and helping people that
want to change their lives
and they want to do something
positive for the community.
- Do you think that
billionaires should exist?
- Yeah, I think it's great.
'Cause there's a reason that
people become billionaires.
It's not like you're a billionaire now.
You know what I mean?
Like they take it.
And the reason that they
are where they are is
'cause they're people
that worked extremely hard
and they have they've
done something exceptional
for the world.
- As you said, that's great.
And that they take,
so,
I don't know about how great
it is that they take something
- It's there.
You know what I'm saying?
Like that's the system that
we've, we've created to, to
you know, make society and
make, make things work.
- But do you think that
system is exploited
usually by these people?
- Yeah.
I think it, if if you want
to get to, to a certain level
you do have to exploit the
system in a certain way.
You can't just play completely fair
'cause otherwise you're
not gonna get there.
There's a lot of billionaires
who do a lot of great things
and they employ thousands of people
and they're really, really
good bosses, you know
especially when you see
people have that have built it
up ground up like Elon Musk
or like there's so many,
so many that are self-made.
It gives people, I feel
like the ambition and
and they feel like they can do it.
- Elon Musk was not self-made.
- Oh, okay.
- He, he came out from the
family of millionaires.
- How do you tip?
- I think here it's like very much so like
this big tipping culture and
a lot of the time I'm like
like for like Uber eats,
like I'm not tipping.
I'm sorry.
I know they're, they're
getting paid to be an Uber
Uber eats driver
and it's like taxes for delivery
fee surcharge on the food.
It's like, bro, I'm not made of money.
I'm not like just giving it out.
- Like just like very briefly.
I did try working for like Postmates.
It's just like a one time
trip just to see how it was.
And they pay really, really low.
Like it wouldn't even make
like minimum wage for like --
- Right.
- You could try, I, I would
suggest you could try doing
an Uber eats just to
see what it feels like
- Hero or villain
- Villain, for sure.
- Why?
- I feel like their
life is generally cooler
and they don't have to
accommodate for as many people.
They sort of just look
after themselves and like
have a lit time and
like the joker, like bro
it's having a fantastic time. -Yeah.
- He is just have having fun
except everyone else is panicking
Like, oh my God, save the world.
And he's just like laughing.
So
- Would you consider yourself your
the villain in your own life?
- Yeah, I'd say I
consider myself a villain,
but it it's like a necessary evil in life
'cause without it then
there isn't the good guys,
you know what I'm saying?
So I feel like there's a balance of that.
- I've seen your Instagram
is, is this to you?
- Yeah.
- So what do you think about that mask?
What does it mean to you versus
like obviously what it means
to other people and how it doesn't really
represent the class that you're in?
- Yeah. I know it's like
anonymous the, the thing
but I just see it as
like a, as like a mask
and that I can like do
something where it's not me.
- So why that mask versus
like a Scooby doo mask or ---
- It's just the most
readily available mask.
- Okay.
- I literally just like you go anywhere
and you can buy those.
- I mean, it all seems kind of nonspecific
'cause that mask has like
meaning to it though,
is what I'm saying.
- I'm on like,
I'm on like the people's
side at the same time
as like, I'm like, oh, I'm
have like this big situation.
Like my father's super wealthy
and everything, but for me
it's like, I feel like I'm
on the side of the people.
You know what I'm saying?
And then that's like, my
ultimate goal is, is to help out
you know,
the, the people that I feel deserve it.
- What have you done that has been
like the most impactful
for you or like the world?
- I think inspiring people
through my videos that get
so many messages saying
like how I've inspired them
and how I've like showed
people how to make videos
in a certain way.
I feel like I help out a lot
of young, young filmmakers
and photographers and
stuff to get into the game.
I'll like bring up people
that wouldn't normally
be getting the opportunity with charities,
I've always seen it as like
this, like you give money
to a charity and then
what it just disappears.
- That's yeah.
- What I like is like you
personally doing something
to someone and then you
see their actual reaction
and the results of what happens now.
- Do you ever worry
about losing your wealth?
- Yeah. Money when I was,
I guess like 16 to like 21
I just wanted to spend
anything as much as I could
- To, to flex like for fun
- Yeah to flex
you know, you'd end up spending everything
on something expensive
and then have absolutely
no money at all
and be living breadlines
until you got your allowance
the next month.
That was what it was like for me
- Allowance?
- Yeah.
- Oh, how much was your allowance?
- It's like $2,000 a month.
Like my dad's always said like,
you know that's all you get.
- That's all you get
Just, if I have like a, an
idea that is gonna make money
then he'll gimme money for that.
He doesn't like to just, he's not
like other parents where
he'll just give me money
'cause like, oh, I want to go on holiday.
You know, my dad he's
he's, he's much older now.
One of the, the big things
on my mind is making sure
that I'm gonna be the man
for my family when, when my dad is gone
'cause
I'm the only one of the, the only son.
So - yeah.
- What would you say is the
hardest part of your life?
- Living up to my dad
I like always have been
in like this, that shadow
like everyone's always
sort of told, told me like
you'll never be as good as him.
You'll never do what he did.
I just wanted to be proud of me.
So like, what I wanted
to do was do something
solely creative, which was, you know
being a film director and, and a YouTuber.
I feel like that's how I want.
I wanna make him proud.
- My dad actually a billionaire as well.
- Wow. Yeah.
- So we're actually in the same boat here.
- That's lit
- Yeah, it is lit.
So I kind of get everything
it come from there.
- Thank God I was waiting for this.
I knew you guys are gonna
pull this out behalf of me.
(laugh)
- Yes.
- Are you in college right now?
- Nah, I don't even go to school.
I just, just kind of living life
doing YouTube, traveling, having fun.
- Well it's lit. We should
make some videos together.
- Yeah am down
- Hey Bobby, seeing
as you're older than Gage, do
you have any advice for him?
- If like your dad gives
you a bunch of money
don't blow it on stupid stuff
- Oh yeah
- Invest it, You know
what I'm saying? - Right.
I wish I can,
like with my trust fund had
bought Bitcoin or something
at least some of it invested.
- Right. - You know what I'm saying?
- What You blow all that money on?
- Fucking nothing.
(Gage chucks)
Like we literally like
30 K a month on Amex,
like staying at the Beverly Hills hotel
for two weeks in a row, like ---
- Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
Paying for all my friends, like - Right.
Like booking, like the first class fight.
And then like, instead of changing it
just missing it and booking another one.
- Yeah but I feel like
everyone needs that experience
to, you know you get a bunch of money
and you lose it all and then you learn
- What's up.
I definitely I've seen you before.
- Its that right?
- Yeah. I've you I've seen some video.
- Yeah - I've seen some videos.
- That's lit. - its crazy
- You make videos as well.
- Yeah.
- Where we definitely tap in - Yeah.